A magazine interview
with Dwayne Johnson,
the only rock
your girlfriend would rather get
than an engagement ring,
has been getting a lot
of attention today
because of one
interesting revelation--
his legitimate desire
to run for president.
I have no problem with this
at all.
I think, compared to Trump,
The Rock is
a much better choice, you guys.
First of all...
(applause, cheering
and whooping)
-First of all,
his tan is real. -(laughter)
Secondly,
his clothes actually fit,
as opposed to Trump,
who always looks
like he's trying to smuggle
a yoga ball in a sport coat.
-(laughter, groaning)
-And if he wanted to,
The Rock could destroy way
more people in Atlantic City.
-(applause and cheering)
-He's amazing. I love him.
I love The Rock.
But here's where
I just have a slight problem.
This is a slight problem,
and please don't get mad at me,
The Rock.
So, this interview with Dwayne,
the Dwayne "The POTUS" Johnson
was on the cover
of GQ magazine's comedy issue.
That's a comedy issue.
The (bleep) comedy issue.
Look at that comedy bicep
-right there on the front
of the comedy issue. -(laughter)
I mean, I guess
this makes sense, you know,
considering next month,
I'm featured
in Fire Hydrant Arms magazine's
"50 Polynesians
Who Can't Fit in a Prius" issue.
(applause and cheering)
But...
GQ, guys, I know you want
to sell magazines, I get it,
but try to understand
what's going on
and what comedy actually means,
all right.
Thousands of comedy folks they
could have put on the cover,
like-- I don't know-- how about
-Chris "The Rock" Rock,
for example. -(laughter)
Or maybe Stephen Colbert,
Maria Bamford, Bill Burr,
Tig Notaro, Rick and Morty,
Kate Berlant, Nikki Glaser...
-(applause and cheering)
-...Hannibal Buress, Louis C.K.,
Norm MacDonald, Noel Fielding,
Dave Chappelle,
Jim Jefferies, Sarah Silverman,
Bob Newhart, The Onion,
Steel Panther...
-(applause and cheering swell)
-...Cheech & Chong.
Cheech & Chong, Ken Jeong,
Ali Wong, Patton Oswalt,
every member of The State,
every member of Monty Python,
every comedian
on Another Period,
who were a lot of people
from The State,
Leslie Jones, Samantha Bee,
John Oliver, Melissa McCarthy,
Kumail Nanjiani, Ron Funches,
a hamster in a sweater,
-or... or this kid.
-(applause and cheering)
-Hello, mother(bleep).
-(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-I mean, so many...
-Wow.
-...comedians
you could have put on the cover
of your (bleep) comedy issues!
I mean, guys,
maybe I'm personalizing
this a little much,
but, like, do the jocks have
to take this one, too?
Do they have to take this one
away from the comedy nerds?
This kind of feels like--
and maybe this is, again,
too personal for me--
but, like, when you're in
Chess Club your whole life,
and then a (bleep) football
player puts on fake nerd glasses
and sits at a chess table,
and that's
the (bleep) photograph
for Chess Club in the yearbook.
-It's, like, they can't
get everything! -(applause)
-Don't get me wrong. I love The
Rock. -(applause and cheering)
He could on the cover
of anything else,
and I'd be fine with it.
He is the world's
greatest action star.
Maybe he's not
actually a comedian?
Like, an official
professional comedian?
Actually, he might not even be
the world's funniest rock.
I think this is actually
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
And...
I think it's safe to say this
one has a much smaller penis.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
But, uh, yeah,
I-I love you, Rock.
Don't hit me,
don't get mad at me. This is...
My beef is with GQ.
You didn't do anything wrong.
-(applause and cheering)
-I just don't understand!
-A big rock.
-HARDWICK: So comedians,
in honor of GQ magazine's
comedy issue, I guess,
please give me
a less appropriate
cover person for a magazine.
Michael Starr.
Billy Joel on the cover
of Sober and Forever magazine.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
-(applause and cheering)
-Right? -Nice job.
Stix.
Oscar Pistorius
on Functional Legs Quarterly.
-HARDWICK (laughing):
Oh, Jesus Christ. -(laughter)
Well, okay. You know what?
Yeah, he did a bad thing.
We can make fun of him.
All right, Lexxi Foxx.
Limp Bizkit on the cover
of Better Homes and Gardens.